Alex Murdoch done with his testimony
after another dramatic day in his double
murder trial the disgraced attorney
admits to being a pill-popping Serial
liar but not a murderer prosecutors
attempting to poke holes in his timeline
of what happened that night
yesterday Murdoch changed his story to
admit that he was at the dog kennels
where his wife and son were slayed
something he did not tell police at the
time
all of this the last time you saw your
supposedly saw your wife and child all
of this detail
you as a lawyer and a prosecutor didn't
think that was important to offer on
your own
well I think it's important and now that
Murdock cops are lying about being at
the kennels he told prosecutors today
that when he left his wife and son
minutes before they were slaughtered no
one else was around for the dogs
barking and carrying on or going out
into the woods or acting like they since
somebody was around that they didn't
know no no they weren't there was nobody
there wasn't around it the dogs didn't
know there was nobody else around all
right good for them
to sense
but the most explosive moment of the day
Murdoch putting forward his own theory
on who murdered his family he believes
it's revenge over a boat accident
involving his now deceased son Paul Paul
was driving the family's boat drunk when
it crashed and killed one of his friends
I didn't believe that any of the
families the people that were involved
in the boat wreck had anything to do
with hurting Maggie and Paul but I can
tell you that at that time and as I sit
here today that I believe that boat
wreck
is the reason why pawpaw and Maggie were
killed so we've got random Vigilantes
because of the boat rack now I don't
know that they're random Vigilantes well
you just said it wasn't the family or
the kid or their kids or the family of
the other kids in the boat right but so
what you're saying is somebody off of
social media and you don't have any
evidence of that do you not you just
believe that you're telling that jury
that as you try to explain the lie that
you told for the first time yesterday
isn't that right no sir that's not right
so what you're telling this jury is that
it's a random vigilante that's your 12
year old the 12 year old five two people
that just happen to know that Paul and
Maggie were both at Mozelle on June 7th
that knew that they would be at the
kennels alone on June the 7th they knew
that you would not be there but only
between the times of 8 49 and 902 that
they show up without a weapon assuming
that they're going to find weapons and
ammunition there that they commit this
crime during that short time window and
then they travel the same exact route
that you do around the same time to
Almeda
that's what you're trying to tell this
jury
you got a lot of factors in there Mr
Waters all of which I do not agree with
but some of which I do
so Judge Pirro how important was it that
Murdoch put forward this alternative
theory of The Killing well look he
started this yesterday uh he he this guy
is without a doubt one of the best uh
not just defendants certainly the best
defendant but the best Witnesses I've
seen on a courtroom stand nobody can put
words in his mouth as hard as they try
no one can pull the wool over his eyes
he is sharper right now than that
prosecutor is and that prosecutor has a
game plan this guy has to have a
terrific memory to be able to be keep
straight on the lies that he's selling
okay but but what's going on today is
that he is consistently added another
possibility and so some jurors gonna say
there could be someone out there who did
this okay but if the prosecutor has any
brains and I don't like that
cross-examination yesterday I'm like I
like him he's a bulldog but you can't be
a bulldog straight for two days the jury
is gone they left after the third time
you stolen you looked in their eyes okay
they're saying he's a liar a thief and a
con man he says I am but the pro problem
is that when he said he left the scene
and he goes back within two minutes all
of a sudden he calls him again why is he
calling mags and papa again and he's
making
293 footsteps he's pacing he's pacing
because they're not answering the phone
but he's only 1100 yards away all he has
to do is get back in the golf cart and
go back there but the prosecutor isn't
making the point the way he should his
summation has to be brilliant it has to
hit all the points that he missed
understand one thing a verdict in a
criminal case a murder case any criminal
case has to be Beyond A Reasonable Doubt
unanimous I would bet my house if
there's one person who's going to hang
on this jury if not more than one he's
got a pretty nice house Harold you want
to take her up on that
well first it's good to be back around
the table
I hope the judge is wrong she has a lot
of experience uh in this and understands
courtrooms and prosecutions and
prosecutors I didn't watch a whole lot
of this admittedly until today and I
read a lot about it uh as we were going
to talk about it today and I guess I
agree with the judge in one huge regard
I think the jury who we never saw uh on
televisions I didn't see my television
at least Fox didn't have it on when he
couldn't see the jury maybe somebody
else did but we couldn't see it
um it all depends on what the jury
believes this man right here did between
8 49 pm and 902 p.m because if you
believe that he lied about everything
before there are a lot of things before
that and you believed he lied about some
things after that which he admitted to
uh and he lied about some things he did
in his own private his personal private
commercial practice in life and he
talked about the law being such an
important part of his family's life uh
and it is and he has an honorable
history his great grandfather his
grandfather great grandfather and father
um how does he not remember that 13
minutes and how could someone have
gotten on the property I do agree with
the judge in this regard if I were the
prosecutor I would have I probably would
have put a big white board up a bit
larger than life Karl Rove like white
board up and just wrote down all of
these things says I would want the jury
to relate as they sat back in that room
to remember what he was doing when he
wrote those things up on that white
board but look I'm not going to
second-guess the prosecution they they
saw what they they saw that jury that
prosecuted had an opportunity I think
his name was Waters but no relationship
and
um and so that he saw what the jury was
thinking and he could see their eyes and
we'll we'll find out here sure I guess
the one question I've had for the judge
not to take this from you Jesse at all
but is what do you think they do well
they have an opportunity to call because
would you call maybe a police officer or
somebody just to re reaffirm and
reinforce for the jury that he lied to
them and when did they think he might
have been lying I would absolutely as a
D.A as a prosecutor right in South
Carolina I don't know I don't know
enough about it you have the right to
offer rebuttal to testimony okay but the
pro the problem is as a judge I'm not
going to allow it because it's not
material to the murder we've already
established that he's lied so I'm going
to say as a judge the jury already heard
that you can bring it up in summation
you can read the record that's it
correct me if I'm wrong but they don't
have a ton of physical evidence right
they don't have the murder weapon they
do have that video that shows you was
around the crime scene at the time
my understanding that it's all
circumstantial evidence so the
prosecutor and Murda himself has
established I'm a liar he's a liar he
lies about everything if he lies about
all these other things why wouldn't he
be lying about killing his wife and son
that's not the standard the standard is
beyond a reasonable doubt on the murder
charges it's not Beyond Reasonable Doubt
on whether he's a liar or not so that's
maybe not going to fly when it comes to
the jury uh deliberating one thing that
he was asked by his defense attorney
before the adjourned for the day was did
you murder Maggie and Paul and he said I
would never hurt either one of them he
did not say
no
so maybe that you know it's very
lawyerly answered to give by not giving
a guess
like that yeah it was it would hurt but
he didn't answer that question and of
course the remaining question is if he
didn't do it who did and the police
clearly don't have any other leads when
it comes to who may have done this right
but judge I agree with you I think that
there's going to be one person who say
might say I don't know I mean there are
plenty of reasons from what I understand
to hate this family and to hate more
than just him and to be so mad at that
kid who was driving the boat and killed
that girl I mean do I think that's what
happened no I think that he killed these
people but actually I think the
prosecutor's plan was to be okay I'm
going to show this guy that this guy's a
liar that this guy's an addict and he's
saying absolutely I am and because I'm
such an addict you know that's why maybe
I behaved in some crazy ways back there
but I would never do this uh and I just
he is doing such a great job and it's
almost you know it makes you hate him
even more because you can see how you
can get away with all of these different
things that they seem to have gotten
away with their entire lives by what the
way he's coming off there after like a
year of a horrendous media about what
trash all these people are to be able to
watch that and have him still come off
as pretty sympathetic judge one thing
but judge when you when in light of what
was said wouldn't you want to call the
police back to at least rebut the fact
that we did explore and we did look into
these other things and we found that
that was not there because no that's
like that's like the defends on O.J
Simpson saying you know uh or the
prosecution say we're going to call
somebody and say you know we already
checked everybody else out no it's an
argument introduced that and he but
I didn't practice like you but I went to
the law school open the door you're
right that's not a material you don't
have to eliminate everyone to be able to
indict this person I'll tell you what
the winner is here for him in terms of
his being acquitted two guns I was
talking to a friend of mine Bill
Fitzpatrick he's the D.A in the Onondaga
County he was the president National
DA's for years we were Pals and still
are he said to me Janine in all your
years in 30 of years and 40 of his at
this point have you ever seen a homicide
scene where they used two guns with one
person I said never he said Janine never
he said I've never seen it you've never
seen it what does that tell you quick
question if he Skates on the double
homicide can he still go to prison for
financial crimes and this is one thing
the jury may say they may say look we're
going to let him go he's going to he's
going to be convicted of the financial
crisis
a long time yeah okay all right hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else